part of the strategy that Republicans
use to maintain this level of
unreasonableness that we talked about in
the last segment part of that strategy
has been to weaponize stupidity I I want
you to hear me out and I know we on the
Left we as progressives and Democrats we
try to be reasonable and we don't like
to use harsh language we don't we don't
even want to call Donald Trump a liar
even though he's proven himself to be a
liar but I want to share tweet on your
screen from someone who writes for this
guy named Jacob wall he writes for
Gateway pundit which is a rag but you
know it's worth pointing out not only
because of how many retweets and likes
it got because I think it is a great
example of how Republicans weaponized
stupidity to their political advantage
and this is what he said on Twitter he
said quote Obama nationalized health
care Obama nationalized the media Obama
nationalized mortgages Obama
nationalized banking Obama nationalized
housing Obama nationalized education and
parentheses Common Core Obama was the
fascist he's doing a couple of things
here but I don't feel like it's
necessary for us to to break down the
illogic of this because it just at face
value anybody with a modicum of common
sense should understand that none of
these things happened I mean I really
wish there's one of my friends on
Twitter said I wish Obama was as radical
as white conservatives are you know say
he was or was afraid of him because of
like it like if Obama was as radical as
they thought a lot of things would be
better in America but he wasn't Obama
said it himself his policies he tried to
set in the 80s he said you know my
policies in the eighties would have made
me a moderate Republican well his
policies today make him a moderate
Republican
there's nothing extreme about Barack
Obama's presidency was so ever he's
extra institutionalist he
did not make moves that he could have
made in order to get legislation passed
because he wanted to respect the
institution's President Obama was about
its milquetoast of a u.s. president as
you can get and that you could take that
as an insult you could take that as a
compliment the fact of the matter is he
was no radical but that's besides the
point the point of this tweet is a
continuation in the weaponization of
stupidity that we see on the right and
the irony of this is is is that the
right is trying to present themselves
now as the intellectuals and they are
intellectualizing stupidity they are
intellectualizing bigotry what they're
wrapping up in an intellectual
presentation in terms of the stage in
terms of the setting in terms of their
wardrobes instead of being in with tiki
torches and burning crosses they're in a
suit and tie and they're speaking in a
presentable manner when the fact of the
matter is what they're passing off to
the body politic is that they're passing
golf extreme ignorant and extreme
bigotry wrapped up in the veneer of
intellectualism but they accomplished
this by dumbing down
they have dumbed down their base to the
point where they will accept drivel like
this saying that Obama nationalized
health care and the media I mean their I
when I pay my premium every month it's
going to a corporation right this has
not been nationalized when when when I
watched the news it's always a private
company who is spreading news across
this country but that's besides the
point they don't care that they are
factually wrong they will not be held
accountable for their factual
inaccuracies they will not be held
accountable for spewing some of the most
ignorant and bigoted bile that we've
seen in generations because their
audience appreciates the fact that at
all cost no matter what comes no matter
what the situation is they are capable
of spinning an issue to attack President
Obama former President Obama
and the Democratic Party and the left in
general that's it it doesn't matter what
you do it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter how ignorant what you say
is so long as you give people on social
media and people watching Fox News the
ability to be angry at the left and to
think that everything conservatives do
is right then then you get a platform
you get a platform and you get a job you
get a raise you get you get funded by
the Koch brothers you get funded by this
conservative think tank or so-called
think tank because you have demonstrated
that there's nothing that you won't be
disingenuous about there's nothing that
you won't lie about and there's nothing
too ignorant for you to share and then
subsequently have it spread across
social media that's all that matters
they have weaponized stupidity because
they understand they will never be held
accountable for what they say in fact
it's the exact opposite not only will
they not be held accountable for the
ignorant things that they say the
revisionist history
there's outright lies and they're
outright spread of bigotry but they get
promoted because of it when your
audience is such that they don't hold
you accountable for anything and they
will agree with anything that you say
then there's nothing that you can say
that will be that will get you in
trouble with the audience first of all
but they love you all the more so you
get a promotion that's how you get
people on large platforms like Jordan
Peterson like the Candace Owens of the
world they are not intellectuals they're
simply wrapping ignorance they're
wrapping revisionist histories like
Dinesh D'Souza like all of these
superstars on the right they're wrapping
their lives in propaganda in the veneer
of intellectualism and that sells like
hotcakes on the right so long as you can
get a person to feel like I'm not really
ignorant even though what I'm saying has
to be some of the most ridiculous and
stupid things that we've heard so long
as you can make people feel okay about
themselves and and the bigotry that they
exist in and the level of ignorance that
they exist in then you get a
motion and you get a platform that is
how they have weaponized ignorant on the
right and we on the left continue to
hold ourselves to a standard which we
should but we have to understand the lay
of the land we have to understand what
we're fighting against we have to
understand that these people are playing
for keeps and there's nothing that they
will not do to win they are willing to
break every rule to rewrite every bit of
history to lie about everything directly
to your face even when you have video /
evidence to the contrary they would do
all of this simply to win and that in
that type of environment you cannot
afford to try to triangulate and
negotiate with them you have to beat
them I'll be with you all week long
David hope you're enjoying your time
away the bonus show is coming up and we
will see you there take care everyone